how's government well welcome to sport
this is really old game but it sure as
hell is a classic let's create a
creature let's create our own species so
we start off with this little blob well
this is pretty [ __ ] gross so far I
don't know where I'm going with this but
let's give him some arms hey hey come on
I'm a what's the cutest mouth that's
[ __ ] pretty man all the [ __ ] at
the club swag swag fish oh nice nice
face you got there he gets to constantly
enjoy the look of his own butthole
he's like barrage oh god what are you
doing stop can we give him more legs yes
he's also constantly slapping his own
ass let's give him a test run oh god
it's like a [ __ ] horror movie why do
I always do this let's go back to the
drawing board what are you I like always
as he's shaky go around it's like oh
yeah oh God well I can't make more legs
that's [ __ ] what the [ __ ] just okay
kill me now let's make it even worse
let's make him more human how about we
make one where he eats himself he eats
his own [ __ ]
that sounds great let's do that this
looks really bad already it's like what
am i doing wait what is happening
oh god dumb hey it's kinda look like
meta Metapod seriously if Metapod was a
spore oh you're pretty oh god he likes
it he looks exactly as anyone who would
be forced to eat his own dick my best
creation so far I need some work you
gotta call this one Bob so what is
happening here exactly and this is why I
have nightmares oh my god it's the lemon
the most deadliest creature on the
planet
swag swag sit fish just slide to the
side let er fly your guy in as I like it
kind of looks like boobs I'm sorry I'm
so sorry wait one final detail it looked
like a headcrab got ahold of his day
he's like yeah damn it not again I'm
sorry what just happened to his face
that's okay though my face often goes
inside my body that's normal I feel like
this is a pretty accurate representation
of life way way to work them thighs
girls oh God
ah yeah this looks really bad
random name Gaber gaber perfect I'm
having way too much fun with this man
what the [ __ ]
once Justin Bieber gets pregnant I'm
pretty sure this is how he'll look like
whoa what the [ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ] what
what in there I just gets better and
better huh oh hey okay this one is Jerry
but I did not mean to do it I promise I
promise
the everlasting vagina this one is
called Patricia Patricia is and then
never-ending battle to fight to catch
her no nipples it just doesn't seem to
work out for her when will she be able
to catch her nipples no one knows
stop Patricia maybe one day okay
just nice ass Patricia I gotta hand it
to you you got a deadly ass I am well
aware that there's something wrong with
me thank you very much Patricia has been
trying to find love her whole life she
just can't find the right one she does
have a great ass I mean come hi I want
to try and make one as human as possible
Oh God
man the maids name oh my god he's
practically a horse face moves batter
lol always ABS - and his little pooper
let's make it a lot of one okay I have a
great idea it turned out pretty awesome
the human centipede this is my best
creation so far he's like well I'll be
damned that's a one fine [ __ ] oh all
right prize that's all the time I for
today
don't forget to leave a like if you
wanted me to play more spore or if you
wanted me to actually play the campaign
or whatever let me know hit subscribe
come read today let's see oh I see revs
in the next one they asked of you
you
he gets to constantly enjoy the look of
his own butthole he's like